-
In the previous video we saw that a vector field could
to record as a scalar field gradient - or, to put it
otherwise, it will be equal to the private one
derivative of our major f in relation to x on and plus the private derivative of
the largest f, the scalar field, with respect to y in j
I record it in many ways to remember what our gradient is
We have seen that if our vector field is the gradient of
scalar field, then we do it 'potentially'
So, f is a potential vector field
-
This also tells us (and this is the most important of them
previous clip) that the curvilinear integral of f is between
two points - let me draw two points here and make a note
the coordinates to know where we are in the xy plane
Axes: Axis x and y axis
Let's say we have this and this points
I have two different paths between them
I have a trajectory 2 that looks like it will
I call it c1 and she goes in that direction
-
And now, I'll take another kind of green, we have
a trajectory c2 that looks like this
They both start here and come here
We learned from the previous video that the curvilinear integral
is not dependent on the trajectory between two points
In this case, the curvilinear integral in c1 by f point dr
will be equal to the curvilinear integral of c2
on the trajectory c2, from f, etc. If we have
potential in any area, anywhere, the curvilinear integral
between each two points is independent of the trajectory
That's the good of the potential fields
Now, what I want to achieve in this video is to add
more significant than those of the previous clip
And this is a very good addition, which
maybe you are obviously anyway
I have already recorded it here
I can just re-order this equation
Let me do that
I rearrange it
I will write this in orange
Thus, the curvilinear integral of the treceria c1 point etc. minus -
I just pull it out on both sides - minus the curvilinear integral c2
of f point dr, will be equal to 0
Here I just took the equation we achieved in the previous video
and I pulled it out on both sides
We learned a few videos before that if it is about
a curve integral of a vector field,
not the scalar field, then the direction
of the trajectory is important
We have learned that the curvilinear integral on, say, c2 from the f point
dr, is equal to minus the curvilinear integral to minus c2
from f point dr, where minus c2 is the same trajectory
such as c2, but in the opposite direction
For example, I can write minus c2 so ...
let him take another color. Let's say it's a minus
c2. This is a trajectory, just like c2, I call it
minus c2, which instead of going in that direction,
goes in that direction
Let us not pay attention to the old arrows of c2
We start here and come back here
This is minus c2
We can put the minus on the other side
and let's say minus the curvilinear integral
on the trajectory of u2 of u is equal to
the curvilinear integral on the opposite trajectory of f point dr
Here I just put the minus on the other side - I multiplied
both sides by minus 1
Let's replace - we have a minus in this equation
the c2 trajectory - we have this and this here
So, we could replace
with that
let's do it
I'll start with the first part
So, the integral on curve c1 by f point dr, instead
minus the curvilinear integral of c2, I will say plus
a minus c2
I'll still get a green color ... We've found,
That's the same as that
Minus the curvilinear integral on this trajectory
is the same as the curvilinear integral
the opposite trajectory
So we say that plus the curvilinear integral to minus c2
of f point dr is equal to 0
Here comes something interesting
Let's see what the combination of
trajectories c1 and minus c2
c1 starts here
Let him take a nice, bright color
c1 begins at this point
And it moves from this point to the curve c1
and stops here
Now do the same with minus c2
Minus c2 starts at this point, goes up and returns
at the same point - makes a closed line
So this is a closed curve integral
If we combine this, we can translate
Remember this is a closed line
As we reverse this, instead of having two curves that begin here
and they're going here, now we're going to start here, we'll go
to here and we will go back on this trajectory,
opposite to c2
This is equivalent to a closed curvilinear integral
So it's the same as a closed-loop integral
We can call the closed trajectory c1
plus minus c2 if we want to be more specific
for this closed trajectory
Here I just plotted random c1 and c2 (or minus c2)
This can be any closed trajectory when the vector field f exists
potential, or when it is a scalar field gradient -
when it is a potential vector field
This can be written as a closed trajectory of c1 plus
the opposite of c2 from f point etc. Here I copied
this means that it will be equal to 0
Here's what we learned from this video
We can call it 'conclusion'
This is a natural conclusion that you can
then make a conclusion
Now we know that if we have a vector field that is
scalar skull gradient in some area, or
maybe in the whole xy plane, this is called the potential of f
This is a potential feature
We will often deal with its opposite value,
but working with negative is easy. If we have a vector field, which
is a scalar field gradient, we call this field
'potentially'
And that tells us that for every point in the prospect we are talking about,
the curvilinear integral from one point to another
is independent of the trajectory - that we learned from
previous video
And that's why an integral, which is a closed loop, ...
if we take some other place and pick up
any other integral that is a closed line, or if we take the curvilinear
an integral of the vector field of any closed line, it will be 0,
because it is not dependent on the trajectory
We learn from this video
if you see something like this:
If you have f point dr and make you calculate
provided that f is a potential field (or that f is a potential field)
is a gradient of another function, or that f is
irrespective of the trajectory), you will immediately say that
it will be 0 - and that will greatly facilitate your calculations
-